merci procès lui il adore de faire des
surprises
j'ai toujours su que tu étais trop bien
pour moi tu seras le plus beau souvenir
de ma vie tu l'aidés jacques je déclare
le malheur en réallouant au joli t'en a
pas marre d'écouter ses connais tu sais
qu'avec la gueule que tu as si le
malheur est hors-la-loi tu es condamné à
mort
[Musique]
sur le présentoir juste en face de loi
non mais
je suis bête j'ai un potentiel érotique
sans limite et j'ai ce petit truc en
plus qui me dommages par me fout car est
tout de suite mon sens ça va passer à
votre rue mais je comprends pas tu mens
nuit en fête et le mec le plus chiant au
monde a privé la barre non pardon j'ai
compris charles
[Musique]
mais charles t chez toi